be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff so as
promised after looking over the various
answers that you all provided in my
video on the Joker's origins what I've
done here is grabbed what I consider to
be the best fan theory on the identity
of the three Joker's which came from
user Tim boy according to him the three
Joker's are actually the same person but
he has hailed from three different
points in time
beginning with Snyder's pale man during
the conclusion of his Batman trilogy the
events of endgame alluded to the idea
that the Joker had been around for over
100 years and had been considered a
demon with pale skin operating from the
shadows and bringing with him different
forms of chaos and death while the
various newspaper clippings as they were
examined by Jim Gordon seemed to support
this claim Tim offered the argument that
the Joker had encountered the Lazarus
pits long before the development of
photography and newspapers and that the
identity of the pale man was given to
him following his encounters with Native
Americans who considered the Joker to be
an evil spirit
as such the pale man identity became
something of myth and legend passed down
from generation to generation eventually
making its way into the lives of
American settlers who began to take up
residence in the geographical area that
would become Gotham City as a result
with the exception of the Joker's
appearances in newspaper clippings and
testimony offered by word of mouth
nothing was known about the Joker's life
prior to his encounter with Batman to
this end
Tim offered the idea that in the early
20th century the Joker adopted the name
of Edward Morgan Blake and in 1939
joined a heroic group of humans calling
themselves the Minutemen all the while
operating under the moniker of the
comedian while Eddie's time with the
Minutemen was short-lived to do to his
attempted sexual assault on Sally
Jupiter he fell into a life of crime
fighting in New York Harbor using
vigilante justice in a manner similar to
that man while the life of Eddie would
lead him down a spiral in the events
leading up to the Watchmen graphic novel
Eddie investigated an island owned by
Adrian Veidt but was unable to process
what he found encountering a former
villain named Moloch in his home and he
began to ramble on in a drunken manner
about what he had seen on veidt's Island
and the end of humanity
however with Eddie's conversation
overheard by Veidt the two engaged in a
scuffle and the comedian was thrown out
of a window where he fell to his death
now where this jump starts The Watchmen
graphic novel Tim
argued that the entire chain of events
was orchestrated by Joker as a means to
kill off the comedian persona without
concerned that anyone would come looking
for him as a result Joker took up the
name Jack and attempted to live a normal
life
engaging in a marriage with a woman
named Jeannie and getting her pregnant
where this would serve as the backstory
as it was offered by Alan Moore in The
Killing Joke Tim argued that this was
actually the Joker attempting to live a
normal life free from the world of crime
however as it was covered in my video on
the Joker's origins Joker himself was
swept back into the world of crime after
his wife and unborn child were murdered
then he was duped into acting is the Red
Hood as a result and after encountering
Batman at the ace chemicals lab the
Joker fell into the VAT his skin was
turned bleach white his hair was turned
green he completely gave in to his
insanity and re-emerged as a Joker that
we know today now while most of this
seems to be entirely disconnected and
loosely brought together Tim's entire
theory hinges on one very important
concept that the inclusion of Grant
Morrison's Final Crisis which centred on
the potential collapse of the multiverse
Batman had engaged in a battle with
Darkseid but was thrown into the
beginning of humanity's evolution after
being blasted with Darkseid's Omega
sanction as a result Bruce Wayne began
to scribble bat symbols on Kade walls in
an effort to keep his sanity and remind
himself of who he truly was following
this and during the events of Batman the
return of Bruce Wayne by Durant Morris
and detailed Batman's journey through
the timestream leading to the current
day and feature the Caped Crusader
encountering various individuals and
significant moments from throughout the
history of earth while this line of
stories didn't explicitly sit around the
Joker using the retcon from Scott Snyder
it could be argued that Batman's journey
through time had unforeseen consequences
and that the Joker's life is the pale
man would have allowed him to encounter
these various bat related incidents and
drawings as a result the Joker began an
obsession with Batman have stretched
over centuries leading out to the -
encountering one another during the
events of Killing Joke meaning that for
the Joker
both he and Batman were something a myth
and legend existing throughout history
of humankind with various societies
offering their own explanations on the
characters and attempt to understand how
they related to the real world
now again while this does seem a little
contradictory something to point out
here is that with the new 52 Batman did
not receive a reboot instead DC offered
the explanation that from the time
Batman first appeared up until the
current day everything had happened over
the course of five years
meaning that this particular bit of time
travel is actually in continuity with
that being said we're going to bring
this to an end and actually thought this
was a really good theory so we're gonna
pose the question a second time but this
time if you guys have YouTube channels
on comics make a video make a video
giving me your theories on who you think
the three Joker's are and I'll actually
spend all next week uploading those
videos onto my youtube channel with that
being said I will catch you guys later
peace